GOALS WHEN A CANADIAN NATIONAL
HOCKEY LEAGUE TEAM SCORES, YOU
CAN BE A STEP C, HEAVY
GAME.HERE.
HE WOULD HAVE HAD TO PUT PUT TO.
SAN JOSE FOR SO MANY YEARS WASS.
HIS RETURN TO THE LINE-UP FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN A MONTH. SUPPT
FROM BARABANOV,O OFF TO THE OILR
THE SPEED OF MCLEOD, IT'S A
GREAT DEFENSIVE PLAY.
HAT LEAD. N
OF TORONTO.TCHES A
KARLSSON.
BONINO RAN INTO THE LINESMEN,
GOT SUPPORT FRFR
HARD OFF TO BURNS.
BONINO IN THE BUMPER, KARLSSON,
HE'LL ESCAPE, SHARKS PEEL OFF ON
A CHANGE.RE AND HOIST IT BEHIND
BOUCHARD.
NOAH GRE BACK
OUT OF THE ZONE.
HE KEEPS H FLOAT IT IN THERE OR.
HERE'S BRASSARD, TOWARD THE NET
AND TIPPED REDIRECTS THIS
ONE HOME.
GETS INTO A SPOT, GOES OFF THE
AILMENTS KEPT HIM OUT.
MEIER IN
IT, ALMOST GETS BROKEN UP RIGHT
THERE.
MEYERS ONE OF THOSEISAITL
ANTICIPATING THE OILER MARKSMAN
MIGHT BE HUNTING ONE DOWN AND
NO
THAT'S SMOKED OVER TOP.
DRAISAITL, BARRIE,
NUGENT-HOPKINS.
HYMAN IN BUMPER BACK
DISHES OFF, KANE SHOOTS AND
OILER TENURE.